[Music]
what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
welcome to winners on a Wednesday this
week I would love to introduce you to
Chris chap he's absolutely killing it
when it comes to rent to rent
particularly in HMOs so he's going to
share his story give you some top golden
nuggets and tips and explain how exactly
he has done it Chris
welcome to the show so give me a little
background what we do prior to property
and what got you into property prior to
property how was that was a contractor
working for national air traffic
services when the country installing
communication sounds so fun it's fun it
was well-paid and it involved a lot of
traveling
before that I was offshore and then
before that I was in the Air Force for
14 years so every job I hardly nents at
this point I was a chaplain I was away
didn't mind it when you're younger 37
now married with it with this small
child your perception on life changes
yeah
a lot of time I'll be spending in the
airports traveling or in the car noise
waste of the day is there's a waste of
an evening waste of a week so I started
how can I get out how can i what can I
do yeah time time that was the big thing
for me yeah how old you little want to
know ah awesome it's nice to finally
know I've got past the first third will
be known for actually three the
difference in life is just was a smiling
face every day so happy for that reason
anyway so how did you hear about
property investing and myself well it
started with with podcast really I
started asking myself questions how can
I do
how can he only equivalent what was
inning and more and go past this beyond
my wildest dreams and be from home and
the only you'll need job that kept going
back to his property so I've got
listened to the podcast it was podcast
podcast podcast and then head on to
YouTube and I saw yourself on YouTube
and that wasn't that wasn't when I first
met you it took me about another year
until I finally went to a crash course
what took you so long I think I am
everything it's time you know when you
find out when you're financially free
you suddenly you can start you start
doing more staff exploring
so I spent the evenings just reading box
reading box reading box reaching out to
people how did you do that what did you
do why did you do that and this seems to
be the same thing and everything
everyone had the same reason almost who
they didn't want to do what they would
do they want to change their life yeah
so what you were like hunting down
successful people and asking them what
they did that's great and you know what
that's why I have you here because
people ask me you know Samuel you've
been successful but and people try and
hunt down my students you just pick
their brains and I think it's a real
gift to my youtube channel to be able to
pull people and like you that when did
you start what did you come on my crash
course like a month ago yes that was
your crash course was my deciding factor
for taking the leap but hold on you've
got nine rent two HMOs got 10 min total
you've just got a tenth when did you get
your first one my goodness so did you
how did you have the knowledge did you
just do it literally just on YouTube or
what and again I can't emphasize how
teaching yourself and reaching out to
people with yeah your YouTube channels
where you know so many little gems and
nuggets on there yeah but you mix that
in with other people's germs and other
people's knowledge and again asking them
you put things together yeah you find
out what works I mean that's a cool I
like that's cool because you know what
the crash course as you know is magical
I'm just I'm just trying to work this
out so you a year ago you found me on
YouTube you've been watching the YouTube
videos you've been reading loads of
books listening to podcasts going around
meeting people but I do in there and
then just and just we're not doing it
but then why were you a skeptic when you
came to my crash course the last month
if you were already doing it and making
money off the back of my youtube videos
because it was working and it was
growing steadily but the success stories
from crash course and how you were
making it look so easy yeah I mean again
my specialty was going to rent HMOs you
talked about how you can get this lease
you get no money down on that and it was
as easy as you say ZZ is this so yeah
and then you were doing it on the course
and then you were other people also fold
up on the Facebook speaks with other
people they were doing it so I thought
again one of the things that got into
this was they're doing it why can't I do
it do you think that you almost went
about it the hard way so you should have
just got the training from me probably
sooner rather than just watching YouTube
but do you dumb really well but it's
funny that you you're doing well but so
you were doing well but you were
thinking I'm doing well it's working
but he probably makes him sound a bit
too easy until you came to the crash
course just in May of course in May I
managed to secure it I was waiting on to
deal to come through and they both came
through and that weekend yeah I came
into a small amount of money and I
thought you know what how did you come
into that money it was a lot we feel the
Air Force know I just might have been a
little bit money so it was had enough
there for safety buffer for you know to
live off yeah and still to invest and
with the renewed confidence of seeing
how it's done for a different level yeah
I can up my game if I focused on if I've
achieved this whilst working full-time
yeah I know you used to constantly met
you've like we're not constantly but
you've sent me a few messages on
Facebook just saying stuff like oh my
gosh I just got another Dale thank you
so much for your videos you know things
like this and then it got to the point
where I was just like and you know you
jot you're on the Academy now it's about
time it's about time and when you told
me you on the Academy and I just thought
this guy is really serious because
sometimes for me when people say you
know I've got this deal I've got all
these deals I'm making this money if I
don't know them personally if I'm you
know sometimes I'm not quite sure how to
take it we're not lying but you know I'm
just thinking either being a bit
optimistic what's going on but then when
you came to the crash course and we
physically met and you join the Academy
and and and you know now things
obviously moved to a slightly different
level and it's still early days but
we'll check check check
Wow responded on Facebook we had some
conversations I just thought you know
what you've what you've achieved in the
last 12 months almost on your own to a
point it's really remarkable and it also
shows that because sometimes people
think that the crash course or already
training the Academy is a magic wand
which is really not what it is is it's a
tool box and it's a bunch of
cheerleaders saying you can do it here's
the tools you can do it but ultimately
every everyone is self-made to a point
because you've got to do the work
yourself I guess it depends on how you
define self-made Arnold Schwarzenegger
says no one's self made everyone's got
to wear out because people have helped
them which I 100% agree with but at the
same time I think everyone's self-made
if your life sucks you've made it that
way if your life is good and you're
doing really well you've made that
happen ultimately the buck stops with
you you are you are the chairman and CEO
of your life Venis I wasn't always plain
sailing there was there was hardships
there was there was some difficult
moments but whenever you face it a bit
my versity you just again someone's done
it you're not the first person to think
you've yeah extent so find out what
people are there to overcome yeah I'll
say that one of my greatest tools is the
confidence of no one else has done it so
you can do it yeah I so try to it we're
step we're standing on the shoulders of
giants you know you don't have to be
alone and it is sometimes lonely as a
property investor
did you not find getting those and I
have many deals it was like certainly
over five even before coming on the
crash course just alone you were getting
the education off of people and podcasts
and YouTube but was it lonely it was
lonely because it was my venture to sell
to do this the wife she'd helps me a
does things with me now not quite
full-time yet with me because she still
studies University but it got to the
point where I needed her to be involved
as well but before that you know the
usual things you know why you doing that
you know
if anything goes drastically wrong here
you're next on the line
yeah are you doing you sure you know
what you're doing and all this lot
skeptics basically yeah just put a
little bit of seed of doubt in there but
if you they were the confidence they
were the confidence of no one that it
can work and it will work and you're
fine way to make it work yeah yeah
that's so cool
sometimes people say you know that all
my success students all of them have
paid I paid my company a ton of money
and and and and while that might be the
case sometimes because they've invested
into the training a lot of having people
what you want because you became
financially free you became financially
free as a result of the free resources
and the free tools that myself and my
team are putting out there but then as a
result of that you'd be crazy not to say
you know what I'm now financially free
as it was all with the free stuff you'd
be crazy to say I'm gonna stop now if
you're in the like-minded people that's
yes it is lonely sometimes do you think
to know what you making progression but
you see other people progress again yeah
environment as such as the Academy
offers yeah so I'm waiting to get
started without and excited to get build
with us but one thing I've found out
since I started putting myself out there
is people come to you the same way yeah
I was going for them yes I've already
you know constantly putting out messages
so the people giving back and I think
that's something where again I want to
give that back to people yeah so it's
twofold success and helping people
that's that's true and the biggest way
that you'll help people is by inspiring
people to show them what's possible
absolutely
you know I'm ask you a question then so
you've got it currently to this day how
many property renter aunts have you got
that are up and running right now as we
speak
I've got right now we've got seven up
and running we've got two that I just
been converted and congrats and that's
the oh my how much about that make that
will make upwards of 12 to 13 a month
we're just doing the final negotiations
that's the minimum how much a month 12
to 13 under par Wow brilliant you know
what that kind of money
1200 pound a month on one deal it's not
bad it's not that it's a bit daunting
when you realize you know it is 10 beds
to fill but if you've done your visa to
due diligence yeah it's in the right
area to market you've got the demand and
it's kitted up right yeah
so first deal first deal talk me through
the numbers where was it how did you
find that the first deal I would say
it's not my best deal but it worked and
it also it was the it was my foundation
for teaching me what what should have
done differently I guess yeah it was
sent out that you know the usual Haiti
no let's go back to landlords right got
some responses back messed up the first
few I wouldn't know how to speak to them
papi nailed the third one spoke with him
but it was very know he knew what he
wanted he was not budging off this thing
and with me being you're still quite
naive and new to it I just thought well
you know it can work if we make it if we
do this if we do I shave the percentages
down a little back and make it work so
you were desperate for a deal I would go
yeah I think you could use the word
desperate lose motivated thank you but
the thing is you don't want to be a
motivated buyer you want to be dealing
with motivated sellers and you want to
be a shrewd investor what's your first
deal trick fair enough so that's it was
it was a nine but hm oh wow Wester so
you sent out some hexamer letters he
responded and said yo Chris I'm
interested but these are the terms
previously he's got he's quite a wealthy
landlord he's got multiple portfolio
there which is why again I lead on top
of this and he'd been proved to let down
by the magic companies they'd let the
plate they trashed the place Italians
these that look I need someone to look
after it it needs this needs this much
investment so I went I put 5,000 pounds
in he put 5,000 pound in which we revamp
the new carpets painted everything
furniture and because it was quite a
tired place tide streaks I've since seen
inside most of the properties on
same street and it's horrible so if I
could make mine just better than theirs
then I know it all work
yeah so we did all that and it's been
forever since right so the how much you
paying the landlord paying him to to
2200 gee that's a big commitment and how
much profit are you making on that day I
make you 950 Wow good job but is it for
now
it's fall now it's fall now we're just
going through the transition that match
the okay so we've got the students all
lined up to start from September and all
the tenancy creams were in place up and
for that point section 21 was served to
make sure everything was okay hunky-dory
pros and cons student let's and
professional let's ring the ring up the
management company now say that the
light isn't working it's broken and it
music the change the ball bright had
some plates and dishes we can't have
because you only just moved in there
well we found out someone wasn't washing
the dishes so I sort of watched him lose
put him in a bin oh my goodness fifty
profit but it's not always this plain
sailing
sometimes people do stupid things people
are stupid so I put on some times okay
and what about the career what about the
pros of a student because you're
changing this one too much do that yeah
alteration whatever you set your
positions that fits 48 went 52 week 50
week whatever you set that's it your
fault and if your landlord happy he is
very happy yes yes since given me three
more properties no I got three insulted
with this landlords and he messaged me a
few days ago talking about how he's
happy now to fund me if he wants if you
see any any properties he'll now find a
properties will go 50-50 on it manage it
do you know what make a good
relationship is always better than a
good deal you got that first deal that
you're going sure about is a big
commitment but now you've got this
ability of the agent I bet you're making
how much money are you making just off
of that guy alone
about two and a half thousand pounds
there we go and that's just three houses
and you've got you've got a whole bunch
more
what's your occupancy rate in total
across all the properties that are
currently up and running at the moment
we are quite a high percentage I like to
think if you're doing anything less than
five percent occupancy it's 95 percent
then you kindly run a little bit wrong
all right all right no if you know when
someone's leaving you yeah lined up so
when that you can't move into list eight
that one's out you know what these
little tips and tricks can be the
difference between an 85 percent
occupancy right and a 95 or even 100
percent in some cases one of the things
that I do when I move a tenant in to our
HMO is it's but a part of the agreement
I tell them that when they give notice
to move or I will have the right to show
people around and new viewings as long
as I give them enough notice they can't
say you know no you're not allowed to
come and show people around and also I
don't know if you've done this but what
we do with our properties is we market
them before they even ready so we have
that we always concentrate on especially
its some of the properties they've had
to do quite a lot of refurbishing I
mentioned when that first one we've done
three since that needs a full briefing
on them we focus on one room yeah get
that room kitted fully fully kitted out
take nice photos get it out onto the
spare room at search of the forums let's
say we've got a property with X amount
of beds all gonna be for this standard
yeah we recently won only came live
three weeks ago two days probably in May
you know what that's such a good trip
trick and what what I do something
really similar is I find that when when
when tenants come and it's at the moment
a building site or or whatever or just
really bland and you say look this is at
the moment show pictures or show a room
this is what its gonna be like they
almost own it and they almost that are
this is what it's going to be like and
this is what its gonna be and you can
get them to put down deposits and
upfront
yeah and they're in on it and then when
they move in it's like I've waited for
this this has been made
and then they'll tend to stay longer you
can get rents quick no voids so that
that really helps that's great ok talk
to me about after you got those three
deals off that landlord what about the
other deals had did you find them the
same way yes same way letters it was one
that came through recommendation through
where I was speaking with a landlord to
speak to him about taking over his
portfolio nothing came of that however
he did recommend me to somebody else and
I got a deal through that another deal
was passed to me through recommendation
again from the other landlord
yeah so it's it's is literally if you
get out there and you starts you know
putting yourself in the right positions
they always do actually start coming to
you yeah I mean how many as you think
you've sent inter or to get to where
you've got to I send out a hundred and
twenty letters so you've probably sent
out what six seven hundred letters right
there we go but people sometimes say I
hear people making excuses saying you
know letters don't work and they hit
they do they might not work all the time
and how many people that say that
letters don't work normally have only
sent out 20 letters well the first batch
is sent out its I got one or two
responses with first response was from
the landlord that I got the three deals
with yeah out of the batch next month
they started it was seven points of
contact what does that mean what does
that mean to me it's more about just
seeing you recognize seven points of
contact explain what that what that is
because it's interesting and people on
internet I use the analogy stop dropping
these in and then you love a sit on
quite peckish yeah and the seven point
of contact is so powerful because
basically statistically on average the
average person needs to hear from you
seven times before in business right so
it's the same as like McDonald's you
know if you see if you see a McDonald's
and then you see a something I don't
know a hungry lion which I know is
popular in Africa but a hungry lion in
England you're gonna every time go to
the McDonald's because you've seen the
more you're more familiar with them
you've seen them on the TV you've seen
them in the newspapers you've heard your
friends talking about them you know them
they've been around a long time and it's
just that that that's unfamiliar they
said they see my letters a year ago two
months ago
I initially approached him in April and
he's one they messed that one yeah I
just offered the wrongs negotiations
things went a bit pear-shaped but we got
on there to go before yeah I mean which
is one thing I will suggest the people
is just even if you do mess up or if you
don't say the wrong way to say the right
words just be nice and for anyone yeah
they'll come back to you yeah
a year later things are going a bit
wrong with this not got the occupancy
where I want is like what you were off
and I like what you were doing could we
do something this time well I flirt with
him cuz I wouldn't know how many people
have thought I really want to remember
the name of the guy who sent me the
letter but I've lost the letter I got
there's gonna be hundreds of people a
year later and that's what you've got to
just be active continually be marketing
to people there ask your question and
Chris who where are you getting the in
who you sending letters do and how you
getting their addresses addresses from
the council speak to the council and
they have a list of all Haiti mole
anyway anyway any property with a term
or license it has the address for the
property itself the landlord's address
and the manager's address so brilliant
it's got everything any bit of
information you want on there describe
you can if you're short on tenants one
of the things that we're looking at
doing is for marketing sweetie
message out to the houses themselves
yeah and say look if you want to read
what I'm grade to this then you can
create a database of tenants oh wow
so you're so your messaging hate your
sending letters to the actual properties
of HMOs okay that's interesting
like to can't keep a database of
students students landscape database of
challenges yeah if you ever do have an
empty room
it's the constantly having to have paid
spare wheel throughout there you can
just MailChimp whom sent out to your
list yeah we've got this that's that's
great
do you manage the Telus yourself at the
moment yes good good yes good because
because at the moment then it's not
completely passive the income because
you're working for which is fine but
when you know how to do it yourself it's
so much easier to recruit someone it's
like when you're dealing with builders
if you don't have the first clue about
property engineer builder a lot of
builders that whip you off they'll pull
the wool over your eyes letting agents
are the same
hmm management companies if you have no
idea how to run a hint tomorrow we start
especially the last I'd say four months
since it became financially free only
two months ago realized then that's yes
I was for lunch II free I don't the
income there to support what we're doing
and bits of profit but then I thought
what I've kind of just create another
job for myself
yeah take myself into the job we're
working what work on your property not
on your property yeah that was the bet
in every process up now so we've started
to hand this out sitting up for the A's
cry what does it mean what's the
difference between working on your
property business and working in it
around you picked me of analogy now I am
working and working in my property
day-to-day doing viewings bookends
fixing washing machines sorting out the
handyman to come and visit instead of
going out looking for the next deal okay
yes things so someone else could be
doing this so what else could be doing
the day-to-day management of the
property then I can use my time better
to build the business yeah not just
maintain absolutely but the fact that
you're now in a position where you've
got ten I know they're not all you know
some of them some of them you've really
just put on the market but ten
properties some of them making up to a
nine point two pound per property you
know really project properties that then
puts you in a strong position because
you've got the knowledge you've got the
experience you've got the money and then
you can employ someone you can get a
management company you can get VA s to
take care of the everyday running costs
still make a nice income yourself you're
smart and I said that
that's the thing that's what it's all
about foot yeah which is your next step
yes
so systemization systemization we've got
we've got systems in process to make it
efficient a lot of the things because
one the move a lot of time there's a lot
of them we use like a phone for
everything so everything system I see
your phone yeah you can answer
everything send from emails and a lot of
cut and paste processes you find him and
you Dropbox documents find it just cut
and place that that's we apply to that
and each generic responds anything you
do to us read files as a process for it
yeah so now I've written I've written up
the process so I can then get someone
else to do that well and then if they
call you so I love that so initial one
of the things will work with you on for
sure in the Academy but you write a
manual of every little thing how you do
it you give that to our manager but then
every time they found you have a problem
then you're like you solve it but then
you write down what happened in the
manual so they don't phone you with that
problem again and then you get and then
it gets to the point where you're in a
position in business where it's like
there might be like every six months a
really obscure problem you know oh my
gosh no one's ever asked me that before
put it in the manual yeah but you know
what though Chris I'm glad that you've
you've put the work in because sometimes
people ask me questions and they'll say
you know how do i systemize this you how
do I make this passive and I always
advise before trying to systemize
something before thinking about the XYZ
plan the ABC that you're your focus when
you're starting out as a property
entrepreneur your sole focus has got to
be to make money when you're making the
money then you have a new problem and
then it's well how do i systemize this
it's a good problem to have when you're
making like five ten grand a month and
you thinking wow I want to start system
wasn't this then deal about the
systemization but don't when you when
you people's problem at first is how do
I get a deal how do I get in with
landlords how do I get tenants which is
a problem that now you've you've solved
yeah but it was only because I still
needed guidance I still need the next
steps yeah you know everyone's got to
step in was at the next level yeah so
this is why you know you can offer that
I could learn the next steps yes
systemization is the next thing for me
whilst I can look on we wants the next
jump there that's cry
so there what's the biggest lesson that
you've learned in the last 12 months
biggest lesson go ahead always always do
you research on what you're doing why
you do with it yeah especially with the
HMOs we found I was only confident that
I could take on the larger properties
and make them work in the special chest
is not the biggest of areas this demand
is there but it's not exactly amazing
yeah so we you have to be in my eyes has
to make sure you're better than what the
other person is yeah and the other
person at the moment they're still very
tired landlords out there you have your
basic Magnolia walls your brown carpets
and you if flat-packed bulky IKEA beds
and you're thinking that's it's not very
good yeah so if you just have to do a
basic freshen up of paint that's great
you know what it's so important because
what when you're going to do a renter
rent do you got to look anyhow you've
got a look at what's the supply what's
the demand and and and if if there's a
lot of supply and you're thinking
there's loads of HMOs already it doesn't
mean that you can't do it you've just
got to be better and when the people
started coming through I was surprised
at how bad what they were offered
previously because they were saying
things like god this is amazing
sign up straightaway and I was thinking
this isn't no this is my first property
this isn't exactly yeah I'll probably I
could but more money in it yeah when
people tell me all this area's over such
write it and I look into it normally
what they mean is this area is
oversaturated with shabby rubbish
yeah it's oversaturated with those but
how many properties in the area and good
quality high standards reasonably priced
on spare room right now probably not
that many there's that there's that
there's there's five hundred rooms
available at the moment but they all
suck apart from 20 of them but then
there's there's there's hundreds of
people looking for homes so as long as
you're in the top top five ten percent
you're gonna fill it I say we start
doing a new thing now as well again this
is it's our way of try
systemize Barbie finally get someone
else to come into it is he's doing blop
viewings as well yes she finally did a
plot few indeed he speeds up the agency
for people Allah put the deposit down
before this person does
so they've just trying to win a lot your
time so when I've got a few minute Court
past half past court till two o'clock
come back for this just do all at once I
know it doubles the impact because they
want to do it there and then as well so
apart from the systemization what's next
for you next for me is how wants to
start looking into commercial to
residential I've started going through
fear already we're bringing two three
Network meeting so far and each one has
been productive in a new way from that a
great contact to come from it so again
skeptical coming to the crash course or
skeptic knows these network meetings why
am I gonna talk about what can i back up
with you know I've only got at that
point you know X amount of properties
four or five not gonna believe what I
say but he gets its building at
relationships yeah if they can see you
can do what you do well enough even at
that level and you likeable people they
see the confidence you've got they'll
trust you yeah then you can just build
from that and so it matter it's I
thought he was just a financial broker I
just thought it was speaking to him
about how to i do bridging for certain
properties and I said I've got this
property I want to look at anyways
they're all our back yet cry so you want
to move on some sort of bigger deals
bigger bigger more stressful deals yeah
yeah because but you know what though as
you grow you your ability sometimes
people say you know I want to do it I
want to know a big deal but they've not
done a small deal yet and I think it's
really important to start to start but
to start out small and then as you grow
like now a renter HMO or rent to rent in
Cheshire you look that up for breakfast
it doesn't scare you
where was a year ago I bet you oh my
gosh went live for the first day on the
first think you know that's a two
thousand or two thousand two and like I
say it's a lot of money to be paying
yeah it's a lot of money what if this
doesn't but now you look what happens
when you become successful and you get
bigger you look back at your old
problems they look small yes then you
find new problems yeah and the
finishing of an entrepreneur is someone
that is always problem-solving you know
and and always stepping out your comfort
zone so I love I love seeing you grow
and you're absolutely killing it so
final words of wisdom then to someone
watching this maybe they're like you and
they're feeling a bit skeptical or a bit
afraid but they want it what's what's
your war your final words of advice
knowing that's anyone else has done it
and that's almost like you've got the
little voice saying it's not possible
they're making it too easy and all this
but then you can so hold on a minute
shut up a little voice let's look at the
facts the facts are someone's done it
yeah every week we have someone sat here
becoming successful
yeah I love that and in hindsight going
back what would you do differently what
I did differently I think the rents
aware cereal I did its I would
definitely do more due diligence with
that one
yeah it's worked it's working but we're
having to really focus at the moment on
marketing with that one it's not it's
not got the occupancy right you wanted
it's not but we know it can get better
there are things we can do to improve it
we are approaching local company so we
can have to share Facebook pages it's
called advertising things but it's
because you've got nine HMOs and then
one si here and the SI is a bit it's
good it's good it's amazing it's just
this it was new to me so I think that
again back to the first first HTML deal
when I said yeah it's been live for a
month I'm a bit well we look forward to
doing part two maybe next year and here
in seeing you is a whole new even bigger
person doing commercial development
having essays systemizing your rent to
rent business well let's make you happen
bro good job thanks for come on the show
awesome so please don't be as skeptical
as Chris was don't watch my youtube
videos for a whole year before getting
down to a property investors crash
course check the link below get yourself
booked on
you too can achieve results like this
and I look forward to seeing you there
real soon thanks and see you next time
[Music]